start with tonight's top story obviously
not really a surprise but in some ways
it is andrew cuomo's days as governor of
new york are officially numbered after a
bombshell investigation by the new york
state attorney general determined that
andrew cuomo was a serial sexual abuser
who
violated state and federal law cuomo saw
the writing on the wall officially
announced his resignation effective two
weeks from today and during a speech
that the new york post editorial
referred to as insulting and only
self-serving cuomo proclaimed that he
accepts full responsibility before
listing all the reasons why he's not
responsible for anything take a look
i take
full responsibility for my actions
i have been
too familiar with people
my sense of humor can be insensitive and
off-putting
i do hug and kiss people casually
women and men
i have done it all my life
it's who i've been
since i can remember
in my mind
i've never crossed the line with anyone
but
i didn't realize the extent to which the
line has been redrawn
according to reports cuomo stepping down
because he had no other options walls
were closing in the governor was almost
completely abandoned by his friends and
political allies i have questions if he
even had any as he made enemies of many
many people in the washington swamp at
least one person was deeply concerned by
today's news despite calling on him to
resign just last week joe biden
complained that this was all so sad
sad because cuomo he done a hell of a
job
take a look
how would you assess
his 10 and a half years
as governor of the state
in terms of his personal behavior or
what he's done as a governor
i thought he's done a hell of a job
i thought he's done a hell of a job
and
i mean both on everything from
access to voting to infrastructure the
whole range of things
that's why it's so sad
can you really say that he has done
quote hell of a job if he's accused of
sexually harassing him
the question is did he do a good job on
infrastructure that was the question
he did
as a governor no the question was
correct me if i'm wrong
how was he as a governor general was the
governor generally obviously outside of
his personal behavior
outside of his personal behavior okay
can you separate the two no i'm not i
was asked a specific question
actually caitlyn collins was right hell
of a job what about the thousands of
seniors who are now dead because of
cuomo's insane executive order decision
that put covert patients in nursing
homes while leaving the covet hospitals
that donald trump built for him 80
percent empty the biggest hospital ever
built at the javits center and of course
the the hospital navy ship what about
the ensuing cover-up when cuomo
allegedly tried to hide the true number
of nursing home deaths according to a
whistleblower to keep that information
from the department of justice what
about the fact that new york state is
home to the second highest coven 19
death rate in the entire country what
about us crushing taxes what about the
crumbling infrastructure the rampant
public corruption apparently it's just
the allegations of sexual misconduct
that trouble joe biden well that's
pretty incredible considering that joe
biden himself he's been credibly accused
of sexual misconduct one former
congressional aide tara reid claiming
that biden violently sexually assaulted
her on capitol hill in the 1990s and
today she called on a real investigation
into joe biden of course a serious
investigation from america's so-called
media mob and independent fact checkers
not likely joe biden the candidate was
in the candidate protection program now
he's in the media mob big tech mobs
presidential protection program national
democrats they're just determined to
protect joe biden at all costs needless
to say cuomo is not currently enjoying
those same protections and with trump
out of office and allegations swirling o
cuomo's value to the democratic party if
there ever really was annie is now
diminished he is no longer the savior of
the left the fawning coverage is gone
and soon cuomo might even face criminal
charges now cuomo joins the la the last
two new york democratic governors that
left office in disgrace the question
tonight is will andrew cuomo face state
or federal charges hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else